[Music]
well such as to NFL players I remember
the Missouri House representatives is
taking a stand against the American flag
as an act of protest he says
representative Bruce Franks raised his
right hand with a clenched fist during
the pledge on opening day of the 2018
legislative session
he said he prefers to quote pledge
allegiance to the people representative
Frank's joins us tonight mr. Franks
thanks for coming on thank you for
having me
so you've got a sweatshirt that says I'm
rooting for everybody black how would
you feel if I hadn't said I'm rooting
for everybody white what would your
response be to that I wouldn't be upset
about it because your shirt didn't say
you're rooting against everybody black
okay so you raised a fist in against
defiance or to tell us what this
symbolic act meant what did you mean by
it
during the Pledge of Allegiance so I've
never said the Pledge of Allegiance and
even in the house last year when I was
in session most of the time I wasn't in
the Chamber's because I know that there
are a lot of people that you know have a
lot of respect and and feel proudly
about the flag and a Pledge of
Allegiance I know how I feel and so my
raising my fist was basically power to
the people to all people all power to
the people invested into the people and
when I say I pledge allegiance to the
people that's why I'm chosen to
represent that's why I'm elected to
represent but even before I was elected
that's who I stand for well good I mean
good for you I think you were elected by
the people and you ought to represent
them when you say you know how you feel
about the flag of the pledge of
allegiance how do you feel so when I
think about the pledge of allegiance um
the thing that sticks out most is when I
hear for liberty and justice for all
we're not think liberty and justice for
all we obviously haven't seen that
across the United States over time over
my 33 years of living we see that there
are when it comes to justice that looks
a little different depending on
sometimes where you from depending on
sometimes what your socioeconomic status
is and what you look like
huh so okay but so does that mean you're
against the Pledge of Allegiance because
it holds those up as ideals I'm confused
no so I understand that they hold those
up my thing is we talk about liberty and
justice for all we repeat a pledge we
pledge of allegience and I pledge
allegiance to the people that's what I
stand for and that's what I stand with
but what about the country and aren't
the people in the country kind of the
same thing or I mean it your bet I don't
know how you feel which is why I'm
asking you but it sounds like you're
opposed to America when you need to take
a stand against the flag and the Pledge
of Allegiance but maybe that's not your
position I'm I'm opposed to folks and
economically distressed communities
being treated differently in America I
am opposed to the way our government
treats our economically distressed
communities our marginalized people in
America we have plenty of veterans who
support me who support our right to
protest no matter what that is even if
they don't necessarily agree many of
them have expressed to me that this is
the very reason why they fall they
fought for our First Amendment rights
and we're not always going to agree on
when we exercise them or what we're
exercising them about right but it's our
right to exercise them yeah well you
won't find that contestant here not and
I agree with you actually that poor
people are treated badly of all races
often want to ask you one last question
you may do recently when lyrics that you
wrote as as a semi-professional rap
artist before you got elected came out
and they talked about killing snitches
and that seemed that seemed like
something maybe you'd want to repudiate
you'd want to say boy I'm I'm sorry I
suggest it was a good idea to quote kill
snitches what's your position on that so
my position is um for one we often hear
about my old lyrics but they don't pay
attention to the new lyrics they don't
pay attention to the new stances
that was at a time when I was an artist
I was using my art I was using my
similes and my metaphors as we do in rap
but I don't stand by those things that I
said as well as we're talking nine years
ago and a great man said don't be so
quick to condemn those who don't do as
you do or say as you say as quick there
was a time when you don't do the same
things do the same things that that you
do now so alright I would like for
people to pay attention to the current
situation and the fight that we were
putting up and the stances that we were
taking rather than all the lyrics from
19 years ago mr. Franks thanks for
joining us appreciate it